thank you
Master Splinter has given us a very
important mission for tonight the target
is across the street
with stealth and cunning to infiltrate
the human world and retrieve
Gogurt
okay Batman what I'm just trying to Hype
you guys up okay that list okay what
else are we getting four quarts of
non-fat milk
bite-sized bag of Cool Ranch Doritos
yeah I like cheese it was very specific
think about the party size he underlined
it twice all right Donnie you're on
toiletries RAF you're stocking up the
pantry and Mikey you're on junkers and
remember don't let any human see you
because why humans are the demon scum of
the earth
to interact with them is to die and hey
I know that's objectively prejudiced but
that's what Dad taught us uh I think
humans seem kind of cool to be honest
Beyonce that guy's the goat would love
to have a champagne brunch with Tom
Brown I fear he seems like a fun hang
and I've always wanted to go to flavor
Town look we all think humans are cool
but we got a job to do let's go
you have bronchitis
[Music]